it's great to welcome back to the
program today Johann Hari who is the
author of the book lost connections
uncovering the real causes of depression
and the unexpected solutions Johan it's
so great to talk to you again
honey David I love your show so I'm
really happy to be back thank you yeah
I'm glad to be able to flesh this issue
out more with you because now that your
books been out a little longer there
have been a bunch of fascinating
interviews that you've done there have
been endless interesting commentaries
about your perspective on depression
some of which agree with it elements
that disagree with it and I think it's
just a great opportunity to really get
into more depth about what you uncovered
and the work that you've done so maybe
just to start let's like recontextualize
depression in 2019 a little bit to make
an analogy there's a lot written about
back pain as a phenomenon and one of the
things we're sort of learning is that
back pain in the way that it manifests
in the West doesn't seem to happen in
some parts of the world and there are
questions as to whether back pain is
more of a result of the sort of
physiological realities of living in the
West and the information age in office
jobs or maybe more emotional and
psychosomatic and psychological and it
turns out that well it seems like it's a
complex combination of the two and
different proportions depending on which
example we're talking about is that a
fair way to also think about depression
in 2019 I haven't looked into this
debate about back pain I'm kind of aware
of it like you are so I don't feel
comfortable talking about that analogy
interesting I think is an interesting
perspective and I'd like to learn more
about the debate about back pain that
you're talking about I think for me I
think you're right
to suggest that this is a question that
is more complex than we've generally
been prompted to think over the last
thirty years I wrote my book lost
connections because there were these two
mysteries that were really hanging over
me the first mystery was I'm 40 years
old and all throughout my life
depression and anxiety have increased in
the United States in Britain and in fact
across the Western world and I wanted to
understand well why right why is it that
with each year that passes more and more
of us
are finding it harder to get through the
day and I wanted to understand it also
because of a more personal mystery which
is that when I was a teenager I remember
going to my doctor and explaining that I
had this this feeling like pain was
leaking out of me I couldn't control it
I was ashamed of it I didn't understand
why it was happening and my doctor told
me a story I now realised was really
well men that was hugely oversimplified
my doctor said well we know why people
feel like this some people just
naturally get a kind of chemical
imbalance in their brain you're clearly
one of them all we need to do is give
you some drugs and you'll be fine and I
started taking an antidepressant called
paxil and I felt significantly better
for a while but not that long afterwards
this feeling of pain started to come
back so I was given higher and higher
doses until for thirteen years I was
taking the maximum possible dose you're
allowed to take him for a lot of those
13 years and pretty much all the time by
the end I was still in a lot of pain so
I started asking myself well what's
going on here because according to the
story that I'm being told I'm doing
everything I'm meant to do yeah I'm
still feeling a lot of distress and
there seems to be a lot of people around
me in a similar situation so for the
book I wanted to use my training as a
social scientist in social sciences at
Cambridge University and my training as
a journalist to really just travel to
lots of different places ended up
travelling over 40,000 miles I wanted to
sit with the leading experts in the
world about what causes depression and
anxiety and people with very different
perspectives and and people who come
through depression in all sorts of
different ways and I learned a huge
amount I think the heart of the answer
you're getting at is I learned that
there's scientific evidence for nine
different causes of depression anxiety
so far there'll be others that we don't
know about yet probably and two of those
causes are indeed in our biology so your
genes can make you more sensitive to
these problems though they don't write
your destiny and there are real brain
changes that happen when you become
depressed that can make it harder to get
out but most of the factors that have
been proven to cause depression and
anxiety are not in our biology they're
factors in the way we live and once you
understand them that opens have a very
different set of solutions
and a very different way of
understanding the pain and distress
that's spread so deeply across our
societies can you talk a little bit
about what were in the travels that you
did yes we talked about 40,000 miles in
the the research and writing of this
book were there any place or or area
where the depression that you learned
about or we're told takes place there or
as prevalent is markedly different than
the majority or the predominant type of
western depression that we hear about
that you can think of where where there
was something different going on in your
mind well there were places where they
had a different understanding of the way
out so I'll give you an um I went to
interview with South African
psychiatrist named dr. Derrick summer
field he's a wonderful person and I went
to see him partly because I was really
struggling with this shift in
perspective from thinking of this as a
problem in my brain which is how I've
been told to think about it how I
thought about it for 13 years to
thinking of it as a wider problem with
many causes in the way we live as well
as some biological causes and it really
began to fall into place me when I went
to see dr. Sommerfeld so he happened to
be in Cambodia in 2001 when they first
introduced chemical antidepressants for
people in that country and the local
doctors the Cambodians that had never
heard of these drugs they were like what
are they and doctor Sommerfeld explained
and and and they said to him we don't
need them we've already got
antidepressants and he was like what do
you mean he thought they were going to
talk about some kind of herbal remedy
like since John's war
junko below by saying like that instead
they told him a story there was a farmer
in their community who worked in the
rice fields and one day he stood on a
landmine leftover from the American
invasion of Southeast Asia and he got
his leg blown off so they gave him an
artificial leg and after a while he went
back to work in the rice fields but
apparently it's super painful to work
underwater when he got an artificial
limb and I'm guessing it was pretty
traumatic for this guy to go back and
work in the fields where he got blown up
he started to cry all day after a while
he refused to get out of bed he
developed all the classic symptoms of
depression
the Cambodian doctors said well this is
when we gave him an antidepressant and
dr. bill was like well what was it they
explained that they went and sat with
him they listened to him they realized
that his pain made sense it was hard for
him to see it in the throes of his
depression actually have perfectly
understandable causes in his life one of
them figured if we brought this guy a
cow he could become a dairy farmer he
wouldn't have to work in the rice fields
it wouldn't be in this position that was
screwing him up so much so they bought
him a cow within a couple of weeks his
crying stopped within a month his
depression was gone they said to dr.
Sommerfeld become Bodhi ins so you see
doctor that cow that was an
antidepressant that's what you mean
right now if you've been raised to think
about depression the way that most of us
were that it's just a problem in your
brain that sounds like a bad joke right
I went to my doctor for an
antidepressant she gave me a cow but
what those Cambodian doctors knew
intuitively from that individual
unscientific anecdote is what the
leading medical body in the world the
World Health Organization has been
trying to tell us for years if you're
depressed if you're anxious you're not
crazy you're not weak you're not in the
main a machine with broken parts you're
a human being with unmet needs and what
you need is love and practical help to
get those needs met this is why the
leading doctor at the United Nations on
this topic in their official statement
for World Health Day said a few years
ago we need to talk less about chemical
imbalances and more about the imbalances
in the way we live now this is not to
say there aren't very real biological
contributions there are it's not to say
that drugs don't give some relief to
some people they do they gave relief to
me for a while but precisely because
this problem goes much deeper than our
biology the solutions need to go much
deeper too and I went to lots of places
in the world from Colombia to an Amish
village in India and Indiana to Cambodia
where people didn't need to be told back
where they knew intuitively that
depression is a signal right depression
is not a malfunction the way that we
we've been taught to think about it in
this culture for the vast majority of
people is to think about depression as
effectively what we're told as a story
think about what my doctor
me again with really good intentions was
your depression is like a glitch in a
machine right it's like a wiring problem
in your brain but actually what the best
evidence shows is while there are
biological contributions that can make
you more sensitive and can pose
obstacles to getting out actually for
the overwhelming majority of depressed
and anxious people we feel these ways
for reasons that sure can be hard to see
when you're in depression I know that
very well and that actually that the key
is to solve the underlying problems yeah
so let's dig into that a little bit
because so ok let's put aside for a
second what we're talking about in terms
of genetic predispositions chemical
imbalances and we'll focus kind of on
the environmental and situational in the
West there are stories about phone usage
and social media makes people anxious
and depressed
there's situational depression after
someone a loved one has passed away for
example which is really sort of a
different category in many cases of
depression there is the sort of
involvement in the neverending
Western vulture capitalist rat race
which can create this sort of like
systemic depression and anxiety and
people can you talk a little bit about
what we mean when we say at least in the
modern West the sort of circumstances
that lead to depression well go through
lots of them in my book lost connections
I think you've gone to a really
important point David I think saying
actually you cover a lot on your show
brilliantly part of the problem with the
biological model right there is some
truth in it there are real biological
contributions to depression but part of
what it's done is profoundly deep
politicize the pain caused by
neoliberalism so what you've had is a
massive increase in depression I think
you and I are about the same at how old
you do and 35
yes we're about the same age you're a
little bit younger than me you know all
throughout our lives depression and
anxiety have increased there's very
strong evidence for example financial
insecurity causes depression right it's
not rocket science if you'd said to my
grandmother or your grandmother gee
grandma do you think if do you think
being really stressed about money is
going to make you more likely to become
depressed my grandmother would have
cooked me round the air and said why are
you wasting my time right
asking me such stupid questions if you
think about many of the factors in the
way we live that have increased people's
depression and anxiety you've seen those
forces and at the same time you've seen
and this is not a conspiracy or anyone
consciously doing this you seen the rise
of a story that says oh no your
depression isn't anything to do with all
of those things the fact that half of
all Americans through no fault of their
own have less than $500 in savings for
if a crisis comes along which is going
to make you really anxious and really
depressed I can talk about some of the
science of how we know that if you like
wellness things people will that's why
you feel that way your pain makes sense
it's perfectly understandable that you
feel that way what we've done is tell
people mysteriously you've all just got
a chemical imbalance in your brains
around the same time as things like
inequality rise so I'll give you some
specific examples of things deep factors
in the way we live and and how we can
deal with them so I noticed that lots of
the people I know who are depressed and
anxious their depression anxiety focuses
around their work so I start looking
what's the evidence around this right
and you guys did a really detailed sorry
Gallup did a really detailed study of
this in the United States what they
found is 13% of us 1 3 percent like our
jobs most of the time 63% of what they
called sleep working you don't like it
you don't hate it you just kind of get
through it and 24% of people hate and
fear their jobs it's quite struck by
that 87 percent of people don't like the
thing they're doing most of their waking
lives and in fact this thing is
expanding over more and more of our
lives as what you know we're constantly
on call started to ask could could this
be having some effect on our on our
mental health so I learned that it was
an incredible Australian social social
scientist named professor Michael Marmot
who made a big breakthrough about this
in the 70s so I went to interview him
and he discovered the key factor that
causes depression at work it's not the
only one it's the key one if you go to
work and you have low or no control over
your job so you just got to do what
you're told you're significantly more
likely to become depressed actually
you're more likely to get sick in almost
every way and more likely to die of a
heart
other problems and and and at first when
I spoke to Professor Marla I remember
actually really misunderstanding this
evidence so I thought he was saying okay
you've got this elite 13% of people at
the top who get to have nice jobs that
they control like you and me great
they're gonna be happy and then you've
got everyone else who's condemned to
this misery and I thought about my
family my grandmother's job was to clean
toilets my dad was a bus driver my
brother is an uber driver I was like
what are you saying these people are
just condemned and professor Marmot kept
explaining to me it's not the work that
makes you depressed it's being
controlled at work and it turns out this
isn't me talking now not him there's an
antidepressant for that so I went and
spent a fair bit of time in in in
several workplaces like this but I'll
give you an example of one I went to
meet a woman called Meredith Keough in
Baltimore and Meredith used to go to
sleep every Sunday night just sick with
anxiety she had an office job as
Meredith would tell you it wasn't the
worst office job in the world she wasn't
being bullied or harassed or anything
but it was monotonous it was boring she
was controlled she had no ability to use
her her mind and a Meredith couldn't
bear the thought this was going to be
the next 30 years of her life so with
her husband Josh she did this quite bold
name and when people hear this the thing
I'm gonna think I'm gonna say you should
all do this too dear listener and that's
that's not what I'm saying it's not
human for a structural change Josh had
worked in bike stores in Baltimore since
he was a teenager
you know it's insecure work you've got
no benefits you don't even have vacation
time unless your boss today needs to
give it to you and one day josh was in
this bike store with his colleagues and
they asked themselves what does our boss
actually do right they didn't hate their
boss he was actually quite a nice bloke
but they were like we seem to fix all
the bikes and this other dude seems to
make all the money they decided to set
up a bike store of their own called
Baltimore bicycle works that works on a
different principle so their place the
place they'd worked before like most
people listen to this they worked in a
corporation right very recent human
invention and it goes back to the late
19th century people know how it works
it's like a dictatorship you got a robe
a the boss sometimes the boss is nice
sometimes he's the equivalent of Kim
jong-un you've got no say over that you
do what the boss tells you and they
decided they were going to set up a bike
that worked on an older American idea
Altima bicycle works is a democratic
cooperative they don't have a boss they
make the decisions about the business
together so in practice they agree most
of the time but if they don't they vote
on it they share out the profits they
share out the good tasks and the crappy
tasks so no one gets stuck with the
crappy tasks and one of things that was
so striking to me spending time with the
people at Baltimore bicycle works was
totally in line with presser marmots
findings by the way was how many of them
talked about how they had been depressed
and anxious before in the previous
places that worked but were not
depressed and anxious now it's important
to say it's not like they quit their
jobs fixing bikes and went off to become
I don't know Beyonce's backing singers
or something right they fix bikes before
they fix bikes now what's the difference
now they've got control over their work
there is no reason we should be
structuring our society so that most of
us are spending most of our time in
institutions that make us feel depressed
anxious or at the very least less happy
and satisfied than we could be every
corporation should be a democratic
cooperative now that's a big thing we've
got to understand some of the causes of
depression that are playing out are big
in our society and catch a one in three
middle-aged women in the United States
at any given time is taking a chemical
antidepressant to get through the day
even more attacking opioids to deal with
their pain to get through the day
psychological pain as well as of course
physical pain and some of these causes
are very deep others are easier to deal
with and I think we've got to be honest
about how deep this crisis goes and how
some of the institutions in our society
and culture are causing that depression
because at the moment what we do is we
say you know you've got this job where
you're humiliated you're controlled you
can't use your creativity in your mind
and you're miserable or there's
something wrong with you right so wrong
in your brain at Krishnamurthy the great
Bengali philosopher said it's no sign of
good health to be well adjusted to a
sick society Johan in the sort of
limited time we have left can you talk
about the things that don't work
particularly well or at least instances
where they don't so like
for example SSRI antidepressants some
people overstate how well they work some
people also understate the how well they
work they work okay for some people
better than placebo to the extent that
they continue taking them and then when
people stop they work a little bit less
well but I want to sort of have a good
understanding without over or
understating the effectiveness of
different treatment modalities well I
think we need to expand our idea of what
an antidepressant is anything that
reduces depression and anxiety should be
regarded as an antidepressant yes you
are lonely you are significantly more
likely to become depressed there are
programs in Britain where they got
lonely people to join gardening programs
it was twice as effective as chemical
antidepressants if you think life is
about money and status and showing off
the things that advertising and
Instagram and everything like them teach
us to believe you are significantly more
likely to become depressed when people
like Professor Tim Kassar at Knox
College in Illinois did research where
they got people to meet and talk about
meaningful values things moments in
their life they have actually found
meaning in connection it caused a
measurable shift in their values away
from some of these forces that cause
depression and anxiety inside although
they banned outdoor advertising because
they could see advertising makes us
depressed it's constantly prompting us
to feel bad if you had a very traumatic
childhood as as I did and you have a lot
of shame about that that is a massive
factor in depression and anxiety and a
dr. Vincent felitti and other people
that I interviewed showed if you give
people who've had traumatic childhoods
safe places to release that shame to see
that it wasn't their fault they were
treated badly that is a massive
antidepressant massively reduces
depression and anxiety so I'm in favor
of a radically expanded menu of
antidepressants on that menu should be
chemical antidepressants they give some
relief to some people which is hugely
valuable they gave relief to me sadly
for a short time and but but real relief
for a time but that menu needs to
include many more things there is
overwhelming evidence this isn't my view
this isn't some cranky view the World
Health Organization the leader
medical body in the world has been
warning us for years that this overly
biological model is damaging people's
health it tells them that their pain
doesn't mean anything if you're praying
if your story is that it's just in your
biology then that says to people that
you just feel this way because of like a
glitch but that's not true there are
biological contributions but we feel
this way for reasons those reasons are
understandable when they're explained to
people it's not like rocket science I
think for example that list I just gave
which is a obviously a partial list I
think everyone listening will have
nodded and gone well of course if you're
lonely if you're taught that life is all
about money if you've had a really
traumatic childhood if you're controlled
and humiliated at work you're going to
be more likely to become depressed and
dealing with those problems together as
a culture will reduce depression and
anxiety we need to restore to people a
sense that your pain makes sense we feel
this way for reasons and together we can
deal with those reasons and one of the
reasons I was really inspired in the
journey I did for my book loss
connections is because all over the
world from San Francisco to Sydney to
Sao Paulo I saw people who were doing
that who were understanding the deeper
causes of depression and were fixing
them together but to do that the very
first thing we have to do is we have to
stop insulting these signals by saying
they're a sign of weakness or a sign of
craziness or purely a biological
malfunction and we need to start
listening to these signals because they
are telling us something we really need
to hear and it's only when we honor
these signals and respect these signals
that we can begin to see the that the
liberating nourishing deeper solutions
the cows that are waiting all around us
we've been speaking with Johann Hari who
is of course the author of the book lost
connections uncovering the real causes
of depression and the unexpected
solutions Johan always great to talk to
you thank you my pleasure thank you for
doing such a brilliant show David Cheers